from NC State Bradley chub joining us
here on the Rich Eisen show once again
how you been bud we're good how you
doing I'm good
- explain to me your situation right now
you draw me the word picture of where
you are right now what you're doing I
have a fun with a little play football
of it with the kids and all that giving
back to the community in there
now I've got a little box of pizzahut in
front of me something to tear that up
uh-huh
so the NFL new pizza the official new
sponsor of the NFL the official pizza
the NFL is feeding you what do you what
do you have are you a topping Scott
Bradley no I got a little pepperoni okay
now this is basically order be careful
now Bradley because the way you answer
this next question you haven't been
drafted yet so there's still more time
to work in red flags do you do you like
pineapple on your pizza
I like pineapples and I like pizza
I like them together Bradley chopped
everybody good answer good answer
Bradley Chavez shooting up draft boards
shooting up draft boards that response
so what are you hearing right now
Bradley tell me the latest you heard
about your situation for tomorrow night
what you're hearing about your draft
position I heard I'm gonna be putting on
the suit and being in the gray room and
I gotta wait for somebody call my name
oh come on now
you haven't heard a specific team which
which team have you heard naki be honest
I haven't heard anything to be honest
with you I don't want it I don't want to
hear it
I'm first all I want to here and just I
want to be around my family and stuff
like right now and wait for tomorrow
all right so how are you tuning it out
are you not going on your phone not
going on Twitter not doing anything are
you in a blackout situation no not in a
blackout situation I mean I see stuff
we'll talk about scroll past it and then
but I go Instagram a lot Instagram just
pictures nobody really targeted look at
it no path to and they hey nobody's
talking about it either so I'm good
so you just I mean just describe for me
your emotions right now as your dream is
about to come true
all over the place to be honest with you
I mean I don't know whether it be happy
nervous excited or what I mean I'm just
right now I'm pretty chill just because
it really hasn't hit me yet but I feel
like tonight and tomorrow is gonna be
crazy
okay and so describe to me who's going
to be with you in the green room mom dad
brother take the law trainer from high
school um girlfriend granddad and my age
and your two agents okay all right
that's better than two girlfriends I'll
tell you no it's definitely better than
that okay he's gonna be he's gonna be in
the NFL shortly okay and what about the
suit shoe situation we were discussing
it last time you were on have you had
that have you nailed this one down yeah
yeah I got I got the shoes they the
shoes came in the other day and I had my
fitting for the suit yesterday and so uh
it's looking real nice together I'm
excited hold on a minute though you your
suit is being fitted yesterday I mean
this is last-minute tailoring or
something like that or is that what this
is yeah I mean it with this one saying
like we just Oh fit I put it on make
sure everything was good okay they got
it steamed and press one right now Farms
wait till tomorrow to put it on the
lining what's in the lining can you
sneak preview what's in the lining it uh
you know my integrand a a astro chub I
know that's your Twitter what your
Instagram name is it different
astronaut okay so what's the lining so
astronomical astronomical love it all
right this is one of my favorite parts
of the journal ready to go on this job I
mean go ready to go hunt now you have
you heard from Von Miller yet or because
I think we were discussing him last time
you were on have you committed with him
no I had I heard him say that say what
he said but I haven't got a chance to
talk to him or anything but we both
would adidas so hopefully we can hook
that up so right so he basically said
that it would be great to have you as
well and I know that the Broncos are
pounding the table for an on quarterback
that they think that the quarterback
yo can win with is already there so is
that a good situation for you there yeah
be a graceful joy just because it's
playing with a guy like that and
learning from them um they'll be pretty
big but I mean any situations good
situation in my opinion okay alright so
uh last thing for you Bradley you're
gonna are you gonna give the
Commissioner a hug there's always these
kinds of conversations you're gonna go
out there and and embrace what do you
got for me when you get out fill out the
valve I will fill out the valve so if
I'm the first one if I get caught number
one I'm gonna have my father going for
the hurt but like if everybody's doing
handshakes and stuff I might go for the
hair so I'm just do it by up door and
play on you're not a trendsetter you're
not a trendsetter like that you know nah
yeah I I am a chance I just don't want
to you know say go out there and throw
my hand out he's looking for the hook or
I'll go for the hug he's looking for the
hair is it awkward okay well when you
come out of the green room you're gonna
look out obviously the Commissioner will
be the first thing you see and there'll
be lots of lights popping and flashing
and cheering them whatever I'm going to
be in the NFL Network set basically to
your two o'clock position okay I think
it's gonna be you're gonna turn you
right and we're in the hard right corner
if you wave with your left hand I'm
gonna take that as a shout out to me and
the Rich Eisen show okay all right let
hair left hand now that is that your
heart would that be your normal wave
hand or not nah I mean I could either go
left hand just so you know especially
right here okay there you go
you know it's for you Thank You Bradley
chub I've enjoyed our two chats pre pre
draft and just know that through the
feud you've come through clean there are
no red flags no red flags is that the no
pineapple on a pizza is a is a major
plus major plus is her good luck we will
see it we'll see you tomorrow night
all right preciate it y'all have a good
yeah it's Bradley Chuck the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience